okay so if you're joining today
is the finals of the choker cup
but even though it's considered the
finals there there's one more match
after this i'll be playing alexandra
botes
and then the winner gets to play hikaru
nakamura next week
who's supposedly kind of good at this
game
so for those not familiar with choker or
the choker cup
there are commands in the chat you can
type exclamation point choker
for links to getting the app for a link
to the rules
of the rules document and the odds guide
and then if you type exclamation point
choker cup
you'll get more information about what's
happening today
yeah so it's the first of three clashes
every clash we start with ten thousand
ships
each it's not real money but uh
it's kind of the currency of this game
i'm going to try and take this seriously
because the steaks the steaks are very
high
and delicious
apparently there's some small issue
which i don't fully understand
but uh okay looks like something's
happening
don't choke it's good advice good life
advice
oh friendly match error maybe she didn't
accept
friendly errors are
are probably preferable over unfriendly
errors
the i feel like the mind games are
beginning before this match
oh she okay she sent me a challenge okay
let's get in game mode um
i won't be really interacting with the
chat there is a delay too i don't know
if i mentioned that
there's a three minute delay ah
deep breath oh something went wrong oh
maybe
something didn't go wrong okay i'm white
no i'm black okay so i'm black which
means i'm
i'm big blind
okay that's the worst starting hand
let's see what she's up to
if she checks i probably just check and
see the next two cards if she bets i
fold
wow what a big raise that's the type of
okay so she's
she's playing aggressively let's fold
i'm slightly nervous just because
there's a lot in the line but
just gonna try and focus on making the
best plays
okay so i'm big blind big blind is 1500
for knight and a rock okay that's pretty
good i'm gonna min race
try and get her somewhat committed
um whoa okay i think
i mean unless she has like queen minor
piece or queen rook
then i mean it's equal let's uh let's
just go all in and
we'll roll the dice it's probably not a
bad strategy for her
because it just comes down to what we
get
okay i like it okay so this is an above
average hand
uh it's valued at 19. um
try not to waste too much time i'm
debating
whether i should put upon d2 or g4
actually not entirely sure
i think yeah d2 normally i like to do
this like
um e2 f3 g4 setup
but with just a knight and keep the back
rank safe
oh that's a good move
um let's
i want to do this properly i mean
very easily i could play e3 the first
move and put the knight on d1
so i cut off any like potential checks
if she places a major piece
on the brc file i'm saving my two
strongest pieces for last
i'm also white so i move first so
there's a few
slightly scary to watch out for this
um
huh i have an idea though and i
might i mean
it's i don't want to take too much time
though
it really comes down to whether i want
to take a risk or not
let's put the queen here i
just want to see your next card i'll
decide whether it's with the rook on
on h1 or g1
it's very i should really think worst
case scenario though
it's very possible she has a better
better pieces than me especially if she
has a queen
then i mean at the very best i'm equal
but i am forking stuff and she's taking
time
and she can only defend one thing
so i'm really curious what she has
like usually if she oh wow she has very
strong hands
um so rook on g1 would be really
interesting
is it possible she has another queen i
don't think that's possible
this is really risky
but okay i have i mean i'm threatening
the queen head on
and i move first i'm the bishop like
when i take the bishop it defends
the queen would defend the rook so worst
case scenario
what can she have i don't think she can
have two queens
because the second queen would get
demoted to a pawn if she has a pawn then
i'm i'm winning
if she has another rook oh rook on h8
oh she has another rook i'm losing i
think
queen a 4 check
that would be really bad if she has
another rook but okay hopefully
she has a bishop beautiful oh
oh but i have queen a4 okay there we go
queen a4 i'll take
i'll take the thing i'll take the other
thing i cover g1 so there's not even
rook g1 and n
she might play rook g1 2 not realizing
like thinking she's winning my knight
no she she sees it so i have a extra
queen
if i win this game then i win the um
the clash because we both went all in
that was a really really important
placement phase
like in the past usually the placement
phase goes really quickly but
uh it was highly highly tactical so i
just have to avoid a mouse slip
i'm going for knight d6 maybe knight c5
as well
i mean it's really just about exploiting
this uh this king
um play d4 and get the pawns involved
let's try and keep the time advantage
too i mean i would prefer
prefer getting getting a checkmate or a
choke mate
rather than rather than going for the
flag
i have a nice pawn chain restricts a
bishop
okay happy to to trade if she wants
uh let's play this move oh she resigned
oh yeah low time
okay so i did i win oh no she had more
chips
do you have more chips
huh
yeah maybe she did have more chips than
me so she's all in by four oh wow this
is terrible
oh this is better okay
that was better um so she was like
forced all in
wow so i was wrong so we we played one
more chest phase
so i'm gonna uh default to my my usual
thing
i did this a lot in the previous match
of putting a pawn on g5
um and then putting a bishop on the
light square probably f7
though she has ideas of
um bishop c6 i don't think it's an issue
though
actually bishop c7 is also an
interesting square
i'd rather rather be safe than sorry
she moves first so the idea is to
probably run with the king
to okay that's a good sign
it's going to say to a square like
like f8 um
yeah what's the best approach here
i guess a rook on rook on h8
i'm not really threatening rook h1 but i
mean she has to show her
her final card oh she has a queen
she has a bishop okay so i'm i have a
much much better hand
uh let's place the queen on b8 yeah
okay i like my chances here
i'm going to try and and win before she
resigns though
even though resigning would maybe
lead to me winning
yeah actually like this is probably one
of the worst possible hands
that like white can have like two pawns
and three minor pieces
i don't know if it can get worse than
that
oh cool guy thanks for subbing for 26
months thanks so much
okay so i'm going i'm going for the
choke mates maybe e2 could be the
mating square also queen b1 ideas
this king is super safe
bishop harry doesn't scare me
last week um botezz gave an interview
saying that i should be scared
and the best the best thing to do when
someone says that
is to not be scared
even though it's slightly scary let's
play on let's play bishop h5
going after this pawn this is a pass
pawn 2 on g5 can start rolling
let's take a pawn
i'm dreaming of getting the queen to b2
and and having the rook defend it so if
the light squared bishop moves
i play queen b2 choke mate i'll pre-move
it just for the
the fans
please move your bishop please ah wrong
bishop
uh let's play oh she wants to play c5
but in c5 queen at check i assume it's
mate somewhere
yeah c5 queen a1 king b3 queen a2 king
c3 queen c2 mates
um this is kind of the same thing
mates let's go that's a good start
so i think what happens we take a a
one minute break or two minute break
and then
okay so i'm going to exit
alexa set the timer for 85 seconds
one minute okay i
forget how long the break is so
hopefully like 85 seconds will be some
compromise
um it's first to three uh wins
uh the match so oh let me oh
i forgot to update the score thing oh
maybe people are confused
my bad um let me
wait score how do i do this
that's the one thing i forgot to do
alexandra
nice spell i can't spell
alexandra botez okay so i have one
one to zero hopefully that's aligned
okay beautiful oh she's challenging me
okay i guess i'll accept
deep breath okay let's do this
so one to zero i need to win
two more yeah i think this happened
earlier where like when i accept
it stalls for a moment but okay
everything looks smooth now
[Music]
i'm white which means i'm small blind
okay ooh queen ooh bishop
um i'm
oh alexa quiet i think i'm going to slow
play this
this is a really good hand i'm going to
call if she bets then i raise
ah okay so she's that gives me
information that she's slightly weak
it's still a very good hand and because
she checked
i'm probably still i mean specifically a
favorite
so yeah i'm gonna i'm just gonna put her
all in make it try and seem like a bluff
maybe
okay i mean that's the best possible
card so i have a value of 20
23 wow a value of 23
just realized that was she's going to
see the demoted queen so she she can
assume that i
the very least have a queen yeah a value
of 23 this is
like very very high on the spectrum of
of hands
um that i think the average value is
somewhere around 15 or 16.
um and i'm okay i'm white and i have i
have uh four long range pieces
so i can generate threats on multiple
sides
i guess there's only two sides of the
board but multiple lines like diagonals
files
ranks ranks are not so relevant i guess
here
oh oh she might have a bishop
let's um let's make her worry on the
other side too
i mean two pawns so there's no way she
has
even an equal hand because i only had
one pawn
unless she has like three queens but i
don't think that's
physically possible
um so the knight's undefended oh but
she's covering eight
uh i'm a little bit conflicted here i'm
gonna just put it i'm gonna put the
bishop on c2
i was thinking i'm putting a bishop on
h2 but then that would block the rook
from
accessing h8 on c2 i have potential
checks
so even in this position i had bishop a4
bishop g6 and
rook h8 to seize initiative and a queen
coming
it's hard to get better than this
now she's probably realizing her doom i
don't think you're allowed to resign in
the
oh i guess you could resign in the the
placement phase
that would be hilarious
i think i think we were requested not to
resign like too early
to show show some choke mates
all right so uh
i mean there's so many options here i
think i'll just put a queen
actually maybe queen on eight i don't
know queen here
at least attack of the undefended piece
and then if she has a queen which is
like the worst case scenario
and puts it on d7 that i have made in
two my bishop g6
king f8 and queen h8 mate
queen he choke mate
time is good too i just have to be
careful not to
lose connection oh she has a rook
uh oh
there's a really funny possibility
like really
how do i set it up though
i i'm envisioning uh forcing the king to
d7
and then uh and casting queen side okay
let's just check
i want to castle queen side with choke
mate ah she runs that way
okay let's play bishop here
if king takes bishop then queen h5 is
made
otherwise that move and now i guess
queen h3
is saving the queen forcing the king
somewhere
undesirable i mean castling queen side
it's not a great move though
i'll play queen f5
so how do i arrange this
um let's bring the other rook
oh let's bring the rook here i have to
suffocate the king first
and then eventually castle queenside
oh 96 is coming
i mean everything's winning but
i'm trying to end this in style uh
okay let's just castle queenside just
for the show casting queen side with
check
oh she counter checks ooh that was
yeah that was not necessary at all
all right i was have i was trying to
have fun
i was just envisioning like a youtube
title casting queen side with choke mate
um okay let's go for just something
simple rook a7
oh she's resisting um king f2
preventing knight e3 i even broke a6
i mean i've optimized all my pieces and
somehow i'm not
i'm not mating yet but
okay now it's i think i think it's force
mates it's king d8
play queen b1 threatening queen b8
oh she flags
i'm not proud of that but okay
so two clashes let's go exit alexa set a
timer for 80 seconds
one minute
okay first two down
i can't get over confident though it's
very important like when you have the
lead you don't wanna
you wanna celebrate too early um
update the score
so i am
i'm one one clash win away from getting
to play hikaru next week
the stakes are are so close
and so high okay um i guess i should
actually get ready to challenge her
um oh she's challenging me alexa cancel
the timer
okay deep breath
so the fact that i won the first two it
should have no
effect on my strategy for the last clash
i should just do
basically do what i've been trying to do
just play the
the best decisions possible um i
kind of have a sense of her her betting
style now
this is a decent hand um it's average
so if she memories as i probably call if
she raises a lot i don't know what i do
okay let's um yeah this is a min raise
let's call
i'm the next okay
so this is a case where i probably just
give up like if she bets i just fold
because in any any hand with a queen
even a book
is probably just better than me yeah
i don't think i've made a mistake there
with calling the min raise
okay so this time in white
i know she does have a very aggressive
range
waiting for opponent's bet uh-oh
oh okay that was almost kind of
concerning
okay this is actually probably one of
the worst starting hands
um i'm already
chipped down
i think i fold and it's one of the
i think it's one of the worst because
another bishop gets demoted to a pawn
so it's it's high likelihood i would get
another pawn
um i didn't want to mess with that even
though like maybe they're possible for
what you'll call it a palace or an
empress type thing
okay so okay my strategy is paying off
um yeah basically calling
or um like folding weak hands and
waiting waiting for an opportunity like
this
oh oh she folds that's so sad and queen
the rook
it's like the best starting hand
so she's still up on chips
blinds are increasing a lot so very soon
we're both going to going to be pop
committed
coupons
um let's raise let's
roll the dice because otherwise like if
i
if i just call i'm pocketed anyway so
i'd rather have some fold equity
i think that was the right play
um i mean it turned out to be the right
play i mean
winning the hand with two pawns which is
it's one of the weakest starting hands
okay so now i'm the chip leader and ooh
okay another case i mean this is a case
where i can kind of slow play it
um but it really depends what she does
here
uh please just go all in please
as she calls she's already kind of pop
committed okay
that's what i like to see so we're gonna
go all in and this is the best possible
case
yeah i mean pawns are kind of expected
okay
so it's still like it was guaranteed
better than average
after the first two cards the value is
19.
values 19. um i mean she might have a
good hand just because she did
she was the first one to shove
okay so i want to
preserve time if i if i win this chess
phase and i
i win the whole match oh wow interesting
strategy
uh i'll get a pawn chain why not it
actually scares me she
didn't place a pawn there so she could
have
she could have three more pieces
okay so guarding a chain she could have
a very strong hand here
what's the worst case scenario she has
queen and queen
and like another rook or something that
could be really bad
oh my gosh it might that might be the
case too
if she has another she has a queen then
i'm down
oh wow she probably has a queen because
she shoved
she shoved with four cards so maybe it
was possible she had just like the two
rooks and
nine pawn
um i mean okay if she has a queen i'm
down a rook and a knight for
two pawns that's hard to come back from
oh my gosh
yeah i could lose i could very well lose
this uh this clash
[Music]
okay let's focus i mean i've i have
experience
playing against her down material
because that one time i sacrificed my
queen 39 times against her
but in this this position it's so
simplified
um thankfully white's pieces are not
super active
and i'm going to try and use time to my
advantage
the queen g3 is an idea and the knight
keeps my king
remarkably safe
and this knight is actually out of play
too
so i can just pretend it doesn't exist
queen g4 good move
i have queen b2
maybe king g7 to start
there's a small trick here of queen h5 i
have rook h8
so e7 is the weakest point
uh if i don't lose e7 then maybe it's
okay oh she wants to play rook h3
i'm very wise so i have 95
95.
oh this is really tough
i really don't know what to do here i
have time to think
85 26.
uh 26 queen before
this is really really difficult i think
i'll play a move like queen e5
just preventing queen e6 and then like
rook h3 it's not
quite a mate threat
might even play a rook g it doesn't
quite work oh she wants to trade queens
oh she also like queen h7 too
i have to take
so i have to keep things on the board as
much as possible
make simple threats like rookie one
and make simple forking threats too
and stay up on time not to ask for in
this position
okay defending i have access to f4
in the pawns are my shield oh that
doesn't work
that's a good move
let's play okay five
oh no it doesn't work either wow this is
so difficult
play this move idea knight f4 just
trying for some initiative
okay knight defends h8 which is nice
knight c6 is scary though okay that's
that's scary
oh that's a mate threat let's play with
a seven
16 seconds
all about the pre-moving now
um
dirty flag let's go
wow did i win i think i won
wow dirty flag oh i feel so bad
i feel so dirty
[Music]
wait i have 20k to zero that's over
right
wait what she has no chips to
wait she's at minus wait what
she's at minus 5k
i'm so confused i i don't think
i i think that's over
the the app got confused cause it's not
used to seeing a flag that dirty
wow okay well nice match
i feel so dirty i think i had 0.1
seconds too
i was surprised she got the like her
last move i think she played with 0.3
wow okay so with the delay
let me um i guess i have to set up for
the
the interview uh me one moment
okay so i'm going to do the interview on
my other computer
and then i think the way it will work
is
also let me okay let me update the score
first i need to find some hand sanitizer
i update the score final score is three
to zero
i'm just saying ggs i don't even know
what to say after that
i hope she didn't break anything
oh is it not over
wait
wait are we playing first two
three or are we playing first of four
first of three wait did we i thought we
played the three
i'm really i'm confused because i
updated the score
wait a few things to to address here i'm
gonna watch the the live stream
the point where eric goes down i think
how did she do
that how did she do that i couldn't tell
but at the reaction i could
that's the only way i knew what was
happening i blacked out and then i saw
her celebrate
a big celebration that was blitz
technique part excellence
technique i'm watching the broadcast
because i don't know what's going on
rule of thumb jeff
move the piece nearest to your thumb
game on we continue
wow that was uh that was wild that was
absolutely wow now
interesting to see though that is uh
that was not a clash win so this boat
test feels good but it is a three to one
lead right now actually well the the pot
is five thousand so miss both says 15k
and uh okay i'm trying to figure out
what's going on here if he wants to take
down and go 3-0 in clashes because
she uh she has a nice chip lead here
wait
oh i see what happened a break might
have to call water break mid game
that was intense good that's what i
don't think we've seen
a game of blitz that went back close on
the clock okay there's some confusion
go 3-0 and clashes because she uh she
has a nice chip lead here
wow wow they need a break might have to
call water break
okay there's a few things to address so
basically what happened
the um the app showed another placement
phase for her
but it showed negative 5k chips
on her side on on from my perspective
it's really confusing it showed
different different things for both of
us
wait i timed out but it showed her it it
showed
it showed that she flagged
right
oh now it's showing okay i don't know
what uh
oh i didn't win wait
i'm watching the replay
oh he's going to win this i think marge
at least two seconds ago
but it's showing her screaming hey no
point where eric goes down i think what
does chad say
so from her point of view she won but
from my point of view i wanted the
reaction i could
that's the only way i knew what was
happening i blacked out and then i saw
her celebrate
celebration that was blitz
[Music]
that was absolutely wild now interesting
to see though
the chess 24 broadcast has both views
but it was
it wasn't showing my view oh no it was
showing her view
okay let me take a picture of this
um oh thank you heckin thanks hacken
so it's something with a lag
compensation because
i i think i know what went wrong with uh
the programming
is that we oh this is really strange
because with the there's some something
with a lag compensation
that i i flagged on her perspective but
she flagged on my perspective and then
the app just got confused
and showed us different things um i
don't know if i can show this
um i can try though
so this is what it looks like i think
yeah so it showed her perspective in the
placement phase
and my perspective uh negative 5000
chips
for her yeah it just got confused so
let's see um
let's see what the developer says
oh confirmed in the back end
oh okay so she won
oh that's so disappointing uh oh let me
switch scenes back
apparently in the back end it showed her
winning
even though it was like um what do we
call that
what's the concept where an electron can
be at two places
at the same time
i forget what it's called there's some
like deep physics
anyway okay apparently i lost that which
i i can't complain about too much
because she was
i mean she was just much better material
wise
i probably should have lost anyway okay
so it's actually
let me update the score now so she has
one
oh wow that's my first clash i've i
guess i've ever lost
man okay i sell i celebrated too early
too
um okay so we're going again
oh can't be too flustered wait to see
i'm i'm the big mind okay that's a good
spot to be in if she raises
yeah so i prefer to check here
let me just minimize stuff okay
oh
um if i have another pawn
i'm gonna play very safe see what she
wants to do
yeah i'm okay because i'm i'm there's a
high probability i'm actually getting a
queen
unless i get a minor piece yeah
let's go let's go okay
so this is called the empress or the
palace
of some sort um i think i want to make a
sizable
bet i think i just go all in
if she's checking she's weak um
and my hope is that she thinks i'm
bluffing and she'll call with a
sub-optimal hand
she folds okay maybe i should have been
raised i don't know
i was that was probably too aggressive
yeah that was just the wrong thought
process let's get started
might head buy some chips
okay another two pawn hand
i think i just fold i'd rather
rather put my chips towards better
things
[Music]
yeah other things like this so i'm going
to min raise
and if for some reason she like raises
oh she raises okay so i just shove
i'm actually curious if i have enough
chips to make the the next big blind
she's raising she probably has like
queen pawn or something
um okay oh queen queen
queen oh okay still not the bad hand
slightly better than average this is uh
value
something to work with so the lesson the
lesson from the previous one is not to
get
into a time scramble where i could
potentially flag or where it's like so
close
oh the schrodinger's cat okay i now see
the chat from earlier
the schrodinger cat okay so i'm gonna
play
just extra safe assuming she has a
strong hand
okay let's focus
um i think a rook is safe here and just
apply some pressure to the bishop
so i'm trying to think worst case
scenario oh she might
again she's this has happened before
where she doesn't have a second pawn
oh she'd have a very strong hand we
could be equal too maybe
um
let's play some knight and knight is
decent here blocking bishop c6
let's also block some back rank check
possibilities
and this bishop is still undefended but
she's gonna move first
okay so if she has a queen
i'm just dead
she has a rook she has a rook i'm up to
exchange
she's another minor piece
actually very curious i mean she likely
has a queen because she she bets so
aggressively
but she's taking a lot of time here
it's really important to keep the time
lead
there's rook ca threatening some mating
ideas
oh she has a queen
i mean i might lose this very well lose
this
oh man
that could be it or rook
actually not sure let's work h8
okay so first things first stay up on
time
is the most important thing i think i
want to play rook g5 in castle
that's some funny idea um i'm expecting
some
queen c8 that's a good move too
your rook a5
just have to try and make things tricky
oh material's not actually so bad it's
two rooks for a queen and bishop or
queen and knight
a queen and bishop she works for queen
bishop okay that's playable
um how to do this she's playing safe
okay let's throw a check
king d2 rook f1
i'm trying to be tricky and rook h2
coming
oh that's a good move
okay there goes my casting rights but
that's okay
just moderately safe
here at h2
i give another four
i'd rook h1 2 maybe
just going after the knight knight f5 is
possible
i'm threatening maybe some rook so
another five bishop g6
the idea is to oh the bishop covers e4
oh she didn't see the bishop could take
my rook oh it's so funny
i just dropped a rook for nothing
okay board vision is so important
do you want to play queen c8
so i have i have to be aggressive i have
to play quickly too
and this is this is completely losing
but at least i have some initiative
wait oh oh now she sees that the thing
covers g1
ah
i think i can maybe take the knight
i mean i probably have to take the night
what's to do
that's another time scramble situation
okay a little bit of time
no oh that was so bad
that was so bad i'm getting choked mated
do i have enough chips i have four and a
half thousand
i probably have enough chips actually
yeah that's enough to make the big blind
it's not over
i mean i'm cops i'm packing it up
obviously
[Music]
it's not over if i if i win i'd almost
double up
okay i'm i'm upset okay this is a good
hand though
i'm upset that i i didn't put up more
resistance
okay good pawn yes okay wow two queens
yes this is what i want it's all over
let's go
let's go
wow how many points is this this is a
value of 25
this is one of the strongest hands i
believe that's a demoted pawn so she
probably
she might have a queen actually um
but it shouldn't be too much to worry
about
though i should always always think
about worst case scenario
uh let's put a rook here just in case i
want to castle
and now look the queens are going to do
major major damage i'm thinking a2 and
c2
and i have all these checking squares
yeah so a2 um there's already one
two there's three checking squares
between a4a and g8
and then on c2 there will be c6 c8 and
g6
and a4 this bishop is so sad
bishop would have been much better on f7
yeah she's she's in for a shock ooh
oh that was slightly shocking what if
she also has another queen
but no like her she had a demoted pawn
so
i'm threatening made in one it's gonna
be hard for her to
like even not get mated if she has a
knight i guess knight on d8
but okay it's completely completely
winning
[Music]
she has a rock and broken d8 similar
um what's the best approach here i'm
just looking for the quickest mate
i think yeah let's just trade queens
and then invade with my queen be careful
not to mouse slip
rook h7 coming
rook b1 i just take it
also g5 let's get some some g5 emotes
g5 will be nice also queen h5
yeah the king is tied down to
was tied down to the bishop it's a
decent move
i can take okay because the bishop's
king the queen's defended
uh let's take here
and then king i fade i play g6 i thought
i'd do this
no stalemates
i'm not going to take the pawn uh let's
cut off the thing
um where's my maze here's my mates
d5 only move and then queen b5 me okay
so i basically double up in chips
and now it's a very close to equal game
blinds are increasing
what's the previous big blind the 3 000
or 4 000.
i mean we're probably just going to be
pop committed at this point
it's 4k so i'm i'm basically pot
committed
so it really just comes down to luck i
have to shove
oh she she's small blind so maybe
there's
some small folding potential
she's taking time that's good and she
might be
okay yeah so i have to shove
i mean she's gonna call she folds
that'll be very surprising
wow she folds wow
i had i had like the weakest starting
hand too but maybe she she had something
similar and she didn't want to
she didn't want to roll the dice so i'm
ahead and chips
after being so low on chips
no i'm
yeah i just shove i mean she's fat
committed it's a good hand
it comes down to this still anything can
happen
let's see some queens
not great not great
okay um what is this slightly
below average i'm gonna have to play
quickly
and just assume i mean
statistically she she would probably
have a similar hand
okay now it's bugging up again because
it says choose a piece to place
um
i'm gonna take i'm taking a picture of
the thing and then
oh wait that was weird okay maybe it's
not bugging
i thought that it just froze and her
time was ticking but
she was taking her her sweet sweet time
that was a demoted pawn so she probably
has a queen
so i'm gonna do my my thing keeping my
king safe
the bishop probably belongs on f2 this
is good structure though
even against um
against my bishop
so it's interesting i could also put a
bishop on b2
a place actually don't know what to do
here
i'll place a rook on is it b1
i'll place our work on d1 and then i'll
decide
i have to go through all the
permutations if it makes sense to put a
bishop
on on b2 it probably doesn't though
i probably should have put the rook on
b1 and then add more potential
this it should be okay and she's taking
a lot of time
i mean from her perspective she might be
thinking i could have a queen
she has another bishop so if i put a
bishop here she defends with a queen
i'm just assuming she has a queen so
let's play safe
if she has rooker worse and i'm better
it's still a fight but if she has queen
oh she has to have a queen ghost
she had a demoted pawn unless she had
three bishops
if she had three bishops no that was not
possible because that would have been
promoted
okay it's like castle so i'm i'm worse
here
oh another game i have to fight okay
so ideas rook b1 bishops are so strong
though
um bishop on e3 and king on f2
basically on castle and get the rook to
h1
these bishops are so strong in the
endgame
i really have to try and keep the time
advantage
so uncasting completes so she pushes the
pawn so i might want to play
even some kind of f5 f4
just setting up i mean bishop e4 is a
strong move but hopefully she doesn't ah
she plays it
so rook h5
and this pawn is so strong
i have to resort to passive defense
maybe f5 still
it's interesting bishop defends
play rook h7
yeah great move or is it a good move
how's a good move or is it
i don't know if i take
ah
trying to be as tricky as possible
and kind of pinned like she could queen
she could take
okay so it goes for this the good thing
about this so i win the
i mean if she takes my rook i win the
bishop it's still kind of a fight
i try and build a fortress
it's going to come down to time again
but i could put a rock on e6
it's actually potential fortress that's
interesting
rookie 6 and then e4
oh let's be careful
so i want to put the pawn on g6
everything's defended
okay with a draw
all right
another time scrambled thing but yeah
pawn on e4
it's unbreakable i think
i might even play for a win at this
point i'm playing for a win
oh wow she blundered i didn't take the
queen
oh that's so bad
i'm going for simplification
not one of these again
wow i flagged it's so hard to move in
this
sort of time scramble so i lost a clash
wow it's 2-2
oh that's so sad i was putting up
resistance
[Music]
wait what wait what's going on
i have 6k wait it shows i have 6k but
shows
i also lost
i assume i lost
i assume i lost yeah
no 6k i was a chip leader what happened
there
i'm just gonna watch the main broadcast
so with the delay um broadcast is
showing here
uh and i might as well i might as well
show it to the stream too
let me switch scenes for a moment
um so so it's showing i have 6k
chips and that was definitely enough
to make the big blind
i just don't know i actually don't know
what the rules because they did have
this in the rules
let me see to find this rules document
oh player briefing
ah that that dance oh that's so that's
so devastating
so okay am i reading the rules
um not okay
so yeah that was just to confirm my i
have uh
the chips so i did lose on time but i
had enough chips to continue
so that's my argument
oh i think
yeah i think based on these rules she
had just enough chips to be declared the
winner but okay we'll see what they say
maybe silence is the best the best
approach here
um i'm becoming rich it's like passive
investing
or maybe like crypto any point this
could go down to zero
it says i timed out
okay 2-2
okay that's what i expected anyway
okay apple restart so the the lesson is
just avoid these situations all together
um which is unfortunate but
hello challenge shall i send next
challenge
should i send oh sorry asap okay
okay sending challenge thank you
something something for a sub
low new men lonely men thanks for
subbing
okay yeah i mean the first the first two
matches i played were pretty bug-free
i think okay it all comes down to this
like whoever wins this clash plays for
caro next week
[Music]
um no pressure i'm white so i'm not bet
first
i'm small blind
broken bishop i'm going to min raise
raise and close out some tabs i don't
want
i actually don't want like any um
anything taking up so much bandwidth
okay she folds small lead
it seems a bit laggier than usual
but okay it's still working just have to
be very careful not to time out
i mean i am plugged into ethernet and we
do have like this is the chess bra
cave so we do have decent wi-fi
she folds beautiful okay so it looks
like she's playing safer
than earlier like earlier she was just
like being very loose and aggressive
so i'm white this time at first
so any all in pot i would win
two pawns i think i'll call it's a weak
limp but she's also playing safe
so she checks okay so she has pawn minor
piece
or okay that's a decent
that's decent decent likelihood of
getting queen
because upon rooker queen i think i have
a 60
chance of getting a queen so let's um
let's min raise again just a very small
bet
i don't think she's trapping me she
could be
okay yeah so this is
um i'm pretty sure the odds were 60
so i've looked that up before um
so i don't i don't think she's super
strong but let's just raise like enough
to try and get her to call because the
pots
yeah okay
um i'm just trying to think of the math
there
and that was probably like folding was
probably her best play just given that
i'm coming off as pretty strong
okay so she's already like almost pop
committed
you just have to get through like one
one chest phase
i'm shoving like what if she calls i
shove if she shoves i'd probably call
a two minor this is like an average hand
wow she's playing very very safe
she has insufficient funds to continue
she folded and then didn't realize that
the blinds were increasing so quickly
is that over i managed to win without
playing a chess phase
i think it's over i'm not expecting to
win like that
what a rollercoaster match
that's a very anti-anti-climactic finish
for such a roller coaster match
okay so what i'll do let's put this in
theater mode
um
and let me have volume 39 left wow let's
see what they say
no she's gonna call okay looking for
that pawn doesn't get it but she didn't
get it
oh do you yeah
uh he's gonna put the pressure on here
oh yeah she yellow works
so folding was a good decision
there you see he went with the sizing
instead of all in i think trying to
entice her into the pot because he was
hoping to play
to keep her in so he didn't want to just
go all in you saw him get ready for the
interview
he still didn't want any part of it
she's lost about half her stack and they
haven't got to the placement phase
either about to join
so she's small blind so oh this is
confusing i'm gonna put that one here
the lousy over expression just getting
the hand stacked
expression
yeah i actually feel bad she's already
down to
she is low
four hands lost four hands played four
hands lost foreign
yeah so her next play is pretty much
full strong okay
so this is gonna be slightly confusing
oh that was a mistake if she's folded
she out of um oh can she not
yeah she's out she's out of chips if she
she shouldn't have folded she had to
play
she won't be able to cover the big blind
she
looks very visibly upset and i think she
maybe
you know blundered there it didn't
realize that that
was the case similar to bill perkins
okay um you know and again it's not like
it was their first match i think
this is uh in the rules and we're live
yeah man i think if you guys want to
watch on youtube it's just a chess 24
youtube channel
maybe a mod can leave a link in the chat
spot where i think that's a mistake in
terms of
but you can also watch here it should be
likelihood again it should be watchable
three
almost to get it and she would have had
a queen potentially
there and just folding and then it kind
of spiraled and she ended up just
folding out
of the match okay so what i'm going to
do because she played so well
once i joined the interview i'm going to
mute myself and hyped up to get the two
to two but that looks like a
uh that's it i mean that's three to two
and pretty anticlimactic but at the same
time it shows you
that there is uh there's some nuances to
the game you really got to be aware of
all possible circumstances you hate to
see it like we still have a few moments
at the same time okay so once the
interview starts i'm going to defeat
myself
because it should come up thanks
thanks for someone sending back
alexandra like that people should
show some support for alexandria
which then gets promoted a lot of work
on twitch lately
um
in my opinion at least top speed chess
player against
eric rosen the man who's got a lot of
fold his way through three matches
so uh eric i understand we are now live
on on chest on chess 24.
um you got you got you you got through
uh
3-2 i mean at 2-0 it looked like you
were you were you're absolutely cruising
and alexandra played some unbelievable
speed chess at the end she
she seems to be able to reel off like
three or four moves in less than a
second i mean i think
in both occasions when you ran out of
time i thought it was her who's going to
run out of time
right yeah i know the pre-moving was was
really impressive
um and she i mean she's a pro in this
like she does a ton of
blitz and bullets and i'm pretty sure
she's been
she's been trained since childhood so
that's slightly terrifying
and even in a situation i think there's
um towards the end
i think the second clash or no the um
the final patch that she won
she had this queen against my brook and
it was so hard for me to remove
yeah yes even though i have this
fortress it's hard to pre-move because
she keeps tracking me and i don't know
where
it's hard to predict her free moves too
it was interesting your strategy there
because i thought what you'd do
is just sit tight you had the fortress
she couldn't win in purely chess terms i
thought
or at least it would be incredibly
difficult to figure out i thought really
that you should just let her
let her check you but you thought that
might be losing because you went you
found this incredibly clever g7 check
and if she takes the pawn you win her
queen and you were actually making the
running i thought maybe
since you were ahead on the clock maybe
you just had to sit there
try and figure it out because by the
time she checks you 20 or 30 times
you'll probably have repeated the
position right you might get it you
might get a draw by repetition
which i yeah i i was honestly expecting
that um
and then at some point i thought i could
try and play for a win
and i was trying to like make progress
with my king i think i missed some
opportunity to
run my king to g7 but uh but yeah she
played remarkably well and not only like
in these these time scramble situations
but also
in like in the betting phases she is
able to get me
to commit with worse hands
and um i mean there were many occasions
where she just had a huge material lead
so i don't know if i could have improved
in some way but um
yeah she was a very very tough opponent
the really interesting thing for us was
that pawn pawn kept coming up on the
first two cards
and it's not clear to us that that's a
fold i mean your strategies were
different
i guess you were judging you're looking
at the size of the stacks of both sides
um before making your decisions but you
do you think it's automatically a fold
yeah it always depends on what the
blinds are
and how much uh each side like is
committed um
because once the blinds get to a certain
point you're almost just
populated with with the big blinds
however
yeah i i'll admit i haven't done the
exact
math on either like like two pawns are
better than upon minor piece but it's
definitely towards the
the lower end of the um the spectrum of
like hand strength
so mm-hmm
like in general you want to you you want
to at least see the next two cards to
see if you're getting promotions
right i mean you you've got a 72 chance
of getting a third pawn on a promotion
if you have two pawns
that's true which is but like even even
uh two pawns plus a rook it's still i
think below
average just in terms of a three three
uh three-piece hand
yes so like it's tricky like and you
have to you
have to account for all these like
potential promotions or demotions and
special hands
so it has been hard to work out the math
but um
that's only these things like sometimes
when you go all in with two pawns it's
it's very much of a gamble
yes i have to ask you about the
queenside castling i thought that was
extremely funny
you set your rooks up one on a one one
on h1 and you could have castled either
side
and then newcastle queenside which i
think took alexandra by surprise took me
spy surprise that's for sure but then
she had a discovered check as an answer
to it have you seen that coming i was
you have to look at the man who might
not have seen it coming
i'll admit i like i was just trying to
like sort of orchestrate some queen's
castle with choke me i thought that
would just be like
the ultimate uh goal for that position
because everything was winning
but then 95 surprised me like i forgot
she could block the check and
discover check thankfully i'm just
already up so much material so
it's yes in the fact yes too much no you
had overwhelming firepower advantage
there in the end
well eric look thank you very very much
for for your performances in these last
last three
match days it's been great and you're
now set up to play hikaru nakamura
but your match ready and he's not he's
been playing conventional chess or maybe
he's practicing on the app
um what do you think your chances are
against ikaru
um yeah it'll be interesting i
i did play hikaru many months ago
in in a choker match where it was not so
formal
and the game was different back then
where the blinds didn't really increase
so it was much much longer clashes
um i'll probably have to go back and
like re-watch and see his his strategies
but um yeah i mean in terms of just
speed chess like he's
he's currently ranked number one in the
world for blitz one of the strongest
bullet players online if not the
strongest
um so i'll have my work cut out but i'm
happy to survive this one and
to make it to next week well we wish you
the best of luck and we look forward to
seeing you there so
eric rosen in in st louis near the the
fabulous chess center
the heart of chess in the usa and now
the heart of choka thanks very much
congratulations and we'll see you next
week
thanks so much malcolm take care and a
reminder to everyone that you can
download
the app from the apple store or google
play get involved join the community
yeah sorry i was muted for a moment
hopefully people tune up here
for the grand finals
okay there's there's still a delay and
there's no way to like
fix the delay without ending the stream
um
so i guess yeah all i'll pr oh nice
graphic
they they upgraded my picture so
yeah a few things to say um thanks so
much
to choker choker the app and chess 24
for sponsoring this event
um despite the the roadblocks hopefully
they can they can work on some of the
technical
issues um i don't know if the app was
was prepared for these
these such dirty time scrambles um
thanks to alexandra for
uh yeah for rolling with the punches
putting up a very good fight like 2-2
was not um not a score i exp like i was
just hoping to like win all the clashes
and it
seemed to start that way but um
hopefully it was entertaining for the
viewers next week
playing hikaru i played him
yeah as i said in the interview i played
him a few months ago
in uh in a choker match but the the game
has changed
i think next week it will be first to
four rather than first to three
um
yeah i don't even know how to prepare
anyway thanks to everyone in the chat
too i do appreciate a lot of new
followers
uh thanks everyone wow a lot of new
followers
um thanks to the the raid
there there was a anna crumbling raid if
anyone else raided me thank you
i hope mods gave you shout outs thanks
to all the new subs gabo tai wind axe
squishy hercules with 500 bits
yeah i don't think um alert box wasn't
really showing up
um i'm reading the chat i know the mic
was muted at some point
but hopefully it's okay
anyway um so what i'll do is i'm going
to
end the stream